I've been here in Scotland talking to
our members also talking about what
we're doing to deliver for the people of
Scotland so I haven't seen the report
but I understand that he tended his
resignation to the Secretary of State
and she's accepted it prime minister why
don't you sack a month ago is this not a
stain on the new Deputy Prime Minister's
judgment here this is about doing things
properly and professionally and when
concerns are raised it's right that
there is a proper process an independent
process that we don't prejudge we allow
it to carry on and establish the facts
of what happened reach a conclusion
that's happened Richard Sharp has
resigned but it's right that we do these
things properly and professionally I
think most people will think that's the
right thing to do has replacement
be a non-political appointment and are
you sick and tired of clearing up Boris
Johnson's mess you know what I'm doing
is focus on delivering for the British
people that's what I'm here talking
about today in Scotland how we can work
constructively with the Scottish
government to deliver for the people of
Scotland just this week almost three
quarters of a million Scottish people
receive direct financial support for the
help with the cost of living the most
Honorable in our society when I was last
here we announced the creation of two
new freeports they're going to create
jobs and attract investment here in
Scotland that's what I'm focused on
doing delivering for the people of
Scotland and the rest of the UK but
should the next person not be a
non-political appointment as I said
right now I'm focused on talking to
people here in Scotland about what we're
doing to deliver for them most of all
the cost of living location prime
minister don't shoot the next person be
a non-political appointment we're
jumping ahead of it there's an
established appointments process for all
these things and it will be right that
we turn to that when the time is right
but right now I'm here talking to people
in Scotland about what we're doing to
deliver for them just thank you very
much latest on Sudan thank you very much
indeed you've got an update from the
team back in London we're continuing to
evacuate hundreds of British people
people should follow the travel advice
that's been put out by the foreign
office I pay tribute to everybody
involved in making sure that this
operation is a success I think we've now
evacuated more people than any other
country something we can all be proud of
and teams are working very hard to do
that they deserve all